well guys we're still in January which
frightens me just saying that and this
is a release that was originally
supposed to come out on Christmas Day
but was pushed back into January never a
good sign is there any way this movie
can be good jack ryan shadow recruit is
directed by Kenneth Branagh and stars
Chris Pine Keira Knightley Kenneth
Branagh and Kevin Costner and this is a
reboot of sorts of the Jack Ryan
character I grew up watching a Jack Ryan
movies I love Hunt for Red October
Patriot Games clear and present danger
the sum of all fears was a bit of a
misstep though to say the least so in
this movie Chris Pine plays a young Jack
Ryan he's a marine he gets injured and
then he has to go into this
rehabilitation program where he meets
Keira Knightley's character who is the
doctor who helps rehabilitate him
eventually he gets a chance to work with
Kevin Costner in the CIA and that's when
the movie really starts and we learned
of this financial scheme that Kenneth
Branagh has character who is a Russian
in this movie is involved with and
they're trying to figure out if this guy
is basically trying to start the next
great depression I wasn't really looking
forward to seeing this movie simply
because of the time that it's coming out
and that tends to happen a lot in
Hollywood movies get pushed into January
it means it's probably not that great to
my surprise this is the first good movie
released in 2014 I actually really
enjoyed jack ryan shadow recruit it took
a while for the movie to really show
itself if you know what I mean for a
while I was kind of wondering where the
movie was going until the main plot
really started to kick in and from then
on I was actually really invested in
this movie the characters were
interesting I was invested in the lead
character I thought Chris Pine did a
good job in the movie the action
sequences were handled fairly
competently there was one fight scene
that of course used that quick cut shaky
thing has been going on lately but it
wasn't like Alex Cross or anything where
you literally can't see what's going on
I just wished it was a little bit better
filmed but for the most part jack ryan
shadow recruit actually surprised me
quite a bit Chris Pine did a really good
job as Jack Ryan I think that he got the
naivete of the character you know where
he doesn't really know that much about
what's going on in the more physical
world of the CIA where people are in
these gun battles and you know spying
and life-and-death situations I really
like that about the character of Jack
Ryan because that's one of the best
things that Harrison Ford brought to
that character was that vulnerability
he was never this hero he was never this
guy who was just like the ultimate
ass-kicker of CIA agents he was an
analyst
and he unfortunately got into certain
situations that compromised him and
those he look and they really captured
that well I thought because there are
times in this movie where he has to step
up and he does get his ass handed to him
sometimes it's not like it's just a 100
percent Jack Ryan's an awesome hero for
America guy he does get his ass kicked
quite often in this movie and I like
that about his character because it
added that level of vulnerability that
the character of Jack Ryan needs one of
my biggest surprises in this movie was
actually Kenneth Branagh as the main
villain sometimes when a director puts
himself in such a major role like that I
don't know but he actually did a really
good job in the movie am I the master of
deciphering correct accents no but he
actually gave a pretty menacing
performance shots lingered quite often
at him just staring at people and he
really started to thinking skies
this guy's kind of a dick Keira
Knightley also was good it was nice to
see her doing an American accent I
actually find that oddly very sexy I've
never heard her do an American accent
before Kevin Costner also pretty good in
this movie having a bit of a career
resurgence as of late I liked his
character I thought he added that mature
depth to the movie where you have a
character who's seen a lot he's been
through a lot
he was hardened you know nothing really
fazed him that much I liked him in this
movie where the movie falters is some of
the pacing issues and some of the story
issues I didn't think the dialogue was
poorly handled but there were certain
parts in the movie particularly like the
first 25 minutes where I was just like
where is this going
is this gonna start anytime soon it's
not I'm not saying was boring it just
felt very jumbled it was almost like
they weren't sure what type of movie
they were making until it hit act 2
where the plot really started to kick in
and then the movie became a movie and it
was very entertaining after that but up
until then I was like is this gonna go
anywhere you know what I mean really
what the Jack Ryan books and movies were
always about were the characters and the
situation's and they tried to present
something believable there are times
when the movie does come off a little
hokey just a couple scenes or like
really that's how they're gonna play
that but for the most part I was
actually very surprised by jack ryan
shadow recruit and I'm hoping they make
more but the second one has more focus
because this movie didn't really have
that until the plot kicked in but once
it did I was enjoying myself I'm gonna
give jack ryan shadow recruit abbey it's
actually not that bad especially for a
January release so guys if you see the
movie let me know what you thought of it
below what's your favorite Jack Ryan
film I would have to say mine is
probably clear and present
danger but hundred October might just
itch its way above that guys thanks as
always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck Minh eyes
[Music]